Google searches about sexual orientation
and gender identity have spiked in the
last 20 years those searches have gone
up by Thirteen hundred percent since
2004 according to an analysis from the
cultural currents Institute and these
questions include things like am I gay
am I lesbian am I trans including also
the word non-binary and some of the even
newer terms this seems to pose a problem
for the pride ideology because the
question am I gay am I lesbian am I
Trans Am I this am I that isn't that
something you're supposed to know don't
The Pride people tell us that that's
something that you know intrinsically
from the moment that you're not just a
teenager not just a child from the
moment you're two years old oh my little
Johnny he picked up a Barbie doll once
that's how we knew that he knew deep
down that he was really a girl so then
why are some people confused by this